bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct au cours de cette édition
express du 14 avril nous accorderons une
page spéciale aux deux premières manches
de la Coupe de France de BMX la
compétition s'est déroulée tout le
week-end et pour la première fois sur
l'arène du vélo Drôme de 50 ans en
Yvelines qui réunissait évidemment les
meilleurs pilotes français et puis comme
d'habitude en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du week-end mais tout d'abord
place au 24e Rallye des Gazelles
elles sont revenues il y a une quinzaine
de jours et d'une marocaine et de cette
24e édition du Rallye des Gazelles se
rallye je le rappelle 100% féminin
composé cette année de 160 équipage elle
ce sont nos deux gazelles yvelinoise
Christelle Lebert et Sophie chevalier
bonsoir à toutes les deux merci d'être
là tout d'abord première question qui me
brûle un petit peu les lèvres on s'était
votre première participation à Soral les
raids des Gazelles vous concouriez dans
la catégorie crossover vous terminez à
une belle cinquième place dans cette
catégorie quel bilan vous tirez
Christelle de cette participation un
bilan ultra positif parce qu'on a été au
bout de l'aventure c'était l'objectif
avec Sophie on s'est éclaté dans tous
les sens du terme parce qu'on a éclaté
également des roues 5 ou 6 les risques
du rallye mais maintenant on peut
changer le roux en 2 minutes chrono il y
a pas de problème
et très très positif on a fait des super
rencontres c'est une aventure humaine
également beaucoup d'entraide entre
filles on a découvert un pays
merveilleux très accueillant très amical
très sécuris des paysages grandios et
variés tout était réuni pour un rallye
impeccable alors vous Christelle vous
étiez copilote Sophie de votre côté vous
pilotiez le rôle peut être un peu plus
dur concrètement puisque le copilotage
est un petit peu différente
pilotage est difficile également c'est
vraiment de la concentration chaque
seconde il y a effectivement donc tous
les paysages qu'on peut rencontrer dans
un désert avec des cailloux des dunes
bien sûr du sable des ornières beaucoup
beaucoup de difficultés donc une
concentration au maximum et c'est très
fatigant et alors est-ce que dans le
dans le désert il y a une majorité de
Dune vous avez beaucoup parcouru de lune
où il y a plus de parties un peu
désertique où il y a de grandes vallées
où on peut un peu plus s'amuser on va
dire alors les dunes il y en a quand
même beaucoup mais nous en catégorie
crossover ont passé plutôt dans des
lunettes mais c'est très difficile aussi
à passer et aussi on avait beaucoup
d'endroits de d'herbe à chameaux donc
sont des endroits avec des végétaux et
des parties de sable il faut cela Lomé
on avait aussi beaucoup de paysages avec
des cailloux des plaines immenses à
traverser des plaines avec des
choux-fleurs qu'on appelle des
choux-fleurs sont des végétaux qui en
fait ressemblent à des cailloux et sont
vraiment très très durs et ça peut
casser une voiture on a aussi passé par
des lacs séchés énormément de paysages
différents
marathon Christelle il y a eu on en
parlait un petit peu il y a quelques
mots déjà des problèmes mécaniques
j'imagine dans le désert non alors sur
notre crossover on n'a pas eu de soucis
mécanique de fiabilité on a eu des
soucis liés en fait à la course à savoir
beaucoup de crevaisons on en a eu 7 ou 8
je crois qu'est-ce qu'on a eu un
pare-brise qui est qui s'est cassé bon
voilà c'est les risques du métier et on
a également un amortisseur faut dire
qu'on avait on avait la gagne avec ce
film donc on est passé sur des gros gros
cailloux et peut-être une fois on était
un petit peu hein peut-être un petit peu
trop brutal donc on a on a cassé un
amortisseur on a réussi à aller au bout
grâce à l'ingéniosité de Sophie
de chez Tartonne qui va bien et aussi le
fait de d'aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
soir rentrer au bivouac et après on a
l'assistance mécanique nous avons donc
des mécaniciens de génie les anges
gardent magiciens qui nous ont vraiment
bien aidés merci à eux l'arrivée était
donnée à Issa ou ira j'imagine que
c'était une belle récompense d'aller au
bout pour cette première participation
est complètement magique on est toutes
ensemble sur nos véhicules sur sur les
coffres selon les selon les véhicules
sur les toits on était sur les toits sur
les plaques de désensablage et on est
accueilli par tous les organisateurs la
population d'Essaouira et là c'est la
fête c'est la fête et c'est magique
Sophie vous aviez effectué un stage
d'entraînement quelques semaines
auparavant avant le Rallye quel a été la
différence entre l'entraînement et puis
la prise de contact avec le désert et
les dunes marocaines et puis cette
condition réelle ce sera les gazelles
alors la formation elle est fondamentale
parce que déjà ça prend à connaître le
pays on apprend à connaître les
différents types de paysages la conduite
avec son son véhicule mais par contre
c'est vrai que on a trouvé que le niveau
était très très élevé dès le départ on a
trouvé que c'était vraiment très
difficile
mais on n'a pas lâché les bras on est
allé jusqu'au bout et on a réussi
d'ailleurs vous avez fini troisièmes au
classement donc c'est quand même des
temps et des parcours corrects quel a
été le moment fort de ce rallier un
souvenir que vous allez garder et vous
allez conserver dans votre
montagne voilà on avait une seule et
même route on s'est dit voilà on va y
aller et puis en fait on a eu la
surprise il y avait des dunes entre ce
passage et on a vu pas mal de gros 4x4
des gros des gros 4x4 que j'allais dire
la marque mais les gros 4x4 qui étaient
complètement tanqués dans les dunes on
était repéré un petit peu en courant où
on pouvait passer sur la gauche ou la
droite on a trouvé un passage on a
dégonflé notre crossover et on est on a
surfé sur les dieux on est passé à côté
des 4x4 qui nous ont regardé avec des
gros yeux et là c'est un moment de joie
immense ah oui à un moment de joie
immense et de fierté on était avec un
autre équipage de 307 et on sait on a
sauté dans les bras les unes des autres
et c'était c'était un moment magique
c'était exceptionnel et ça fait
énormément plaisir
ce qui a eu un moment compliqué on sait
que parfois dans le désert c'est un peu
compliqué on se perd la navigation ça
peut être difficile il y a eu ces
moments compliqués que vous avez vécu
j'étais complètement perdue et c'était
vraiment une des rares fois dans ma vie
où j'étais vraiment perdue et on l'a
enfin je l'ai attribué à la fatigue en
fait finalement puisque finalement on se
repose en passant une nuit dans le
désert à attendre le lendemain matin en
reprenant un petit peu de repos le
lendemain ça y est c'était reparti la
fameuse marathon numéro 2 où nous avons
quand même mis 8h pour trouver une
balise
la CP6 ça va se qu'on les connaît par
cœur la balise numéro 6 on a eu à 14h et
la balise numéro 7 à 8h le lendemain
matin donc c'était long mais on l'a eu
dernière question avant de vous de vous
laisser repartir justement vous êtes
prêtes pour une nouvelle expérience pour
pour 2015 c'est déjà dans les dans les
tiroirs ou pas alors on est complètement
prêt à repartir il faut savoir que cette
année nous étions partis avec notre
entreprise qui nous finançaient
entièrement et pour repartir il nous
faudrait un financement externe donc
voilà
-moi
on a quelques contacts on va voir
comment on peut concrétiser ce projet
merci beaucoup à toutes merci beaucoup
de 2014 d'être venu puis on a suivi avec
beaucoup de plaisir votre aventure à
très bientôt peut-être
on passe tout de suite à notre page
spéciale BMX
je le disais dans le titre de cette
émission ce week-end le vélo de Rome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines
accueillait ça toute première
compétition nationale de BMX et avec les
deux premières manches de la Coupe de
France de la discipline chez les hommes
la deuxième journée a été remportée
comme la veille par contre-caleyron de
Saint-Étienne après ce weekend le
Stéphane war en profite d'ailleurs pour
devenir leader de la Coupe de France
élite 2014 samedi lors de la première
manche quand un Caleyron avait devancé
justement son partenaire de l'équipe de
France Simon Duchêne très à l'aise déjà
à Montigny sur place avec nos envoyés
spéciaux Olivier Maniscalco et Patrick
Jacques Denix
très bonne sensation après la piste est
vraiment dur physiquement
et du coup je m'aperçois que ça a bien
marché cet hiver l'entraînement donc
piste dur mais pour moi tout va bien
c'est un super équipement ça pour
travailler mais avec l'équipe de France
c'est un très bon équipement ouais ouais
c'est sûr après encore quelques petites
choses à régler mais ouais il y a
vraiment de quoi bosser ouais c'est sûr
vous le savez le BMX c'est une
discipline pour le moins spectaculaire
et dangereuse aussi pour les pilotes
souvent exposés aux blessures lors de
leur Runner cela a été malheureusement
le cas du membre de l'équipe de France
romain Mahieu qui s'est blessé ce samedi
Olivier Maniscalco a recueilli ses
impressions dans le paddock
avec Romain Mahieu qui hier finit
huitième de la finale avec une petite
chute je crois romain oui petite suite
en finale sur la section pro donc un
deuxième ligne
5 gravité une petite douleur à la
cheville donc c'est pour ça que je roule
pas aujourd'hui mais ça devrait le faire
pour pour la semaine prochaine et à
Manchester qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
justement que tu nous racontes la suite
et ben je suis arrivé dans le paquet en
fait en deuxième ligne j'arrive un peu
plus vite que les autres et j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu attaquer sur la deuxième
bosse un peu trop j'ai un peu été trop
gourmand et c'est là que j'ai accroché
et sur la troisième j'ai fait un peu un
vol plané et j'ai raté comme je pouvais
et je me suis un peu tordu la cheville
donc voilà justement tu as décidé de te
conserver un peu te préserver un peu
pour la suite du programme justement la
suite on en parle à la suite c'est voilà
mardi on part à Manchester pour la
première Coupe du Monde de l'année
donc je préférais pas pas rouler pour
pas me blesser aujourd'hui pour être sûr
de d'être en forme pour Manchester donc
voilà ça va être la première grosse
grosse course de l'année donc impatient
d'y être la piste malgré tout tu l'as
trouvé comment là ce nouvel équipement
pour le BMX français la piste est je
suis déjà venu rouler là elle était un
peu refaite donc le but c'était mieux là
c'était plus roulant ça roulait bien
ça allait ça allait c'était pour faire
des courses ça allait un peu un peu
longue enfin le tour ça pique un peu
mais dans l'ensemble ça allait très très
physique très physique c'est c'est des
relances partout chaque virage c'est une
relance et des grands virages donc ouais
ça prend du jus et si l'équipe de France
de BMX vous le savez a pris légèrement
s'écartier au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le team France
n'est pas encore totalement installé les
biens les Bleus viennent seulement y
effectuer des stages temporaires et à
chaque fois la piste évolue l'objectif
obtenir un tracé proche des meilleurs
circuits mondiaux
ici voilà tout est réuni dans le
vélodrome il y a quand même pas mal
d'installations
ici une piste de BMX donc il va encore
évoluer petit à petit pour vraiment se
rapprocher
d'une piste de préparation olympique
avec son retrouve sur notamment les
Coupes du Monde de BMX
allez on passe tout de suite après cette
page spéciale BMX au résultat du Week
et tout d'abord du foutus c'est une
victoire au bout de la nuit pour les
Templiers lors de cette sixième journée
du championnat de France élite les
joueurs d'Emmanuel Charest recevait ce
samedi soir les Cougars de
Saint-Ouen-l'Aumône au complexe sportif
d'Élancourt mais les Templiers entame
très mal la rencontre et son rapidement
mené de 17 points mais au forceps et
après plus de 3h20 de jeux les Templiers
s'impose finalement de quatre petits
points 39 à 35 avec 5 victoires pour une
défaite cette saison et en Corée
désormais dans les meilleures
dispositions pour les playoffs une
victoire d'ailleurs qui permettra au
Templiers de préparer idéalement le
match de l'année prévu ce samedi
Élancourt retrouve le gothar européen
avec un premier match de poule en Ligue
des Champions face au blitz de Londres
vous nous offrir nous vous offrirons
pardon pour l'occasion une émission
spéciale d'avant match des 19 heures
avec au total 4 heures consacrées au
foot US une rencontre que vous pourrez
suivre en intégralité sur TV fils dès
20h et on rediffusion ce dimanche des 16
heures en baseball encore une se rend
compte compliqué pour les Cougars de
Montigny pour le compte de la deuxième
journée de Division de lésigny-montin
accueillez les boucaniers de La Rochelle
et dans le premier match du matin face à
un excellent lanceur de La Rochelle
Montignac cumule les erreurs et
s'incline en 5 manches 18 points à deux
dans le second match les cougars
réagissent et s'impose de justesse 14 à
13 il va falloir encore travailler pour
atteindre l'objectif de fin de saison
vous le savez les demi-finales de
playoff en roller ok avant la relégation
annoncée les chocs d'Élancourt jouaient
leur dernier match en National 2 ce
week-end avec un déplacement à Cholet
les joueurs de Benjamin Ferrand n'ont
pas terminé leur parcours sur une bonne
note malheureusement des fêtes 8 buts à
3 retour donc à la Scène Nationale 3
pour la saison prochaine handball
handball féminin 19e journée de
Nationale de il y avait un choc da
outsiders entre Montigny 5e et
Villemomble 6e mais les villes Montaigne
se sont inclinées 28 à 22 statu quo au
classement chez les jeunes 9e journée de
la phase finale du championnat de France
des moins de 18 ans plaisir recevait la
lanterne rouge l'alliance Nord lors d'un
match plein les plaisirs rois se sont
facilement imposés 36 à 22 et remontent
à la quatrième place il y avait aussi de
l'Ultimate ce week-end là tout d'abord
on voit le résultat de football ce n'est
pas grave match en retard donc je le
disais de la 11e journée de Division
d'Honneur Versailles vous l'avez vu
c'est incliné de business face à lacets
bébé il y avait aussi de l'Ultimate ce
week-end le les 10 ans du 0ène le
tournoi fêter c'est c'est dix années le
traditionnel tournoi annuel d'Ultimate
organisé par le club de plaisir 8
équipes se sont affrontés pendant deux
jours au Palais des Sports vous le savez
l'Ultimate est un sport auto arbitré et
mixte ou bonne foi et fairplay sont de
rigueur au thème au terme des deux jours
de compétition c'est l'équipe de la
famille Jérémie originaire de carrière
sous Poissy qui s'est imposé pour la
quatrième fois sur l'épreuve ce qui fait
revenir en fait chaque année les équipes
au zérotène ce sont peut-être les
trophées du tournoi créé spécialement
pour l'occasion et toujours de façon
très originale
une année on a fait on a fait des lampes
alors on a pris des lampes dans la forêt
en suédois qui est pas loin on les a
redécoré on a fait des tableaux une fois
donc les tableaux pour chacun on a fait
de la de la pâte à modeler enfin voilà
c'est c'est toujours très narcissique
très sympa le trophée lui fair-play
c'est autre chose c'est un collier de
bœuf donc c'est très massif gravé dessus
tous les anciens makers et le vainqueur
part avec son trophée et le ramène la
ramène l'année suivante
dernière info avant de nous quitter du
de la box éducative un grand bravo jeune
boxeuse du Boxing de la verrière au
championnat de France minimes qui se
déroulait à la Pommeraye à côté d'Angers
hymen Zoé Guy décroche la médaille d'or
dans la catégorie moins de 76 kg et sa
partenaire d'entraînement quand finit
Traoré obtient quant à elle le bronze en
moins de 68 kg et tout cela pour leur
première saison sur les ring bravo elle
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 pour merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur tvfilm à la
semaine prochaine